have you flub the celebrity interaction
DJ khed who I was getting in my Freaky
Friday music video I'm on the way to his
house to shoot his line I was going to
pitch him on a number of things and I'm
texting my director of the video look my
dream version of what I would want him
to do be completely naked be like I'm DJ
cow and like make some sort of Dick joke
about like whatever we think like his
dick is like as soon as I sent the text
I realized I didn't send it to the
director I sent it to DJ Cal oh okay
I've never even met him so he answers
the door but he's acting very normal
he's like so what do you have in mind I
bailed on the idea of even pitching
anything envelope pushing I'm like I'm
DJ K why am I yelling and he was like
huh what else you got I like thought he
would just have accepted that
pitch I was like we could we could like
make a dick joke and he
went a dick joke so he had never heard
the term the term yeah like you know
like I make jokes about like my dick
being small all the time he was like
let's just do the first
thing